the month-long build-up of Russian
troops on the border with Ukraine has
turned now into an invasion
Crane's president accused Russian forces
of firing at Europe's largest nuclear
power plant the city of butcher Bears
witness to the brutality of War Ukraine
claims it fired land-based missiles that
struck the cruiser off the coast of
Odessa the Asos style steel plant the
last remaining part of mariopol not
under Russian control
had a second Surprise counter-offensive
by the ukrainians
the partial mobilization will involve
drafting about 300 000 Personnel the
main Bridge linking Crimea with Mainland
Russia one of Russia's most vital supply
lines Ukrainian soldiers are pushing
into the southern city of croissant
we're going to be with you Mr President
for as long as it takes